[موسيقى]
على كل من القاهره
صباح الخير يا سهام ازيك يا رب يكون يومك
حلو صباح الخير يا عم مصطفى ان شاء الله
منور
كنت في الاول بتصنع الكور ودلوقتي بتصلحها
واتشهرت ب ترزي كره القدم كلمنا بقى عن
القصه بتاعته
وبعدين انا اشتغلت معه وتعلمتها وكنت
بسمعها برضه لحد التسعينات كده لما الصين
طب في ناس بتجيب لك كور عزيزه عليها ناس
[موسيقى]
والله انا بشجع الاهلي بس بنشجعك الفرق
الحلوه
كوره كويس
انا شايفه كمان ان حضرتك رغم انك يعني شخص
محاضره مو كبير في السن الا انك لحد دلوقت
متمسك بشغلانتك ومكمل فيها ومش عايز
تسيبها
اخذتها توارث وقلت ايه خليك ماشي فيها
ابدا ما بقاش فيه يعني الحمد لله
فما فيش حد دلوقتي في مصر كثير فانا خلاص
كل الناس عرفتني
وما اقدرش استغنى عن الناس لان انا تعودت
ان انا اتعامل مع الناس
كان الفتره اللي فاتت كمان كنت ترند جدا
على السوشيال ميديا بسبب انتشار صورك وناس
كثير جدا قعدت تنشرها وتشيرها وكده شفت
التريند ده تبعك
كثير قوي اه
نرجع لك ثاني يا سهام طيب ندى بدي اسال عن
العم مصطفى
اللي كانت كده عزيزه على قلبه في
المباريات
سهام وزينه البرنامج بتسالك ايه اكثر
الكرات اكثر كره كانت عزيزه على قلبك من
اللي انت صنعته
بس في مثلا كوره معينه كنت اعملها لنادي
معين كنت عندك حماس كده وشغف وانت بتعملها
كالعاده الواحد الذاكره برده زي زمان ان
انا بقالي اكثر من 30 سنه باصلح دلوقت
فالواحد برده ايه همم بيجيء لي حاجات واحد
يجي يقول لي عزيزه علي قوي والنبي واعمل
معروف
هصلحها لي رجعها لي زي ما كان باعملها
لان انا واخد طبعا المهنه عن والدي
وراثه وبرده ولازم برده على علمتهم بس ما
بيشتغلوش فيها دائما الكوره
ليها جماليات وليها حتى يعني كل كره ليها
الوانها ولها شكلها وليها جمالها فتصلحها
ده كمان مش سهل انك ترجعها زي ما كانت دي
حاجه مش سهله
الحمد لله يعني الواحد
فيه يعني خبره وفي ثقه ربنا يديك الصحه
ويخليك دائما عندك شغف انك تكمل شغلك نرجع
لك ثاني احنا كنا فخري ندى انه كره
المونديال في العالم مصطفى